meteors are bombarding our planet on a
regular basis
here it's estimated there are over 6 000
hits
they start off as asteroids in our solar
system
trajectory sends them hurtling as
meteorites
most are small and do little destruction
but one day we could get hit by a big
one
and if it's more than a kilometer wide
will have catastrophic consequences
we know that the dinosaurs went extinct
by an asteroid or Comet that hurt the
Earth millions of years ago but we want
to be able to do something about that
going forward in the future
so for years NASA with help from 28
countries has been working on a
planetary defense system
the goal to keep us safe from the one
that could end it all
[Music]
of the Falcon 9 and dark
Dart which stands for double asteroid
redirection test is the first mission of
its kind
of known humans have known for a while
that the Earth is hit by materials from
space all of the time asteroids and
comets this has gone on for billions of
years that's not new what's new with
dart is taking that first step to
potentially do something about that
Nancy Chabot is a planetary scientist at
the Johns Hopkins Applied Physics lab
near Baltimore and the coordination lead
on the DART program so the target for
Dart is a double asteroid system and
there's two asteroids there there's the
larger didimos which is about 780 meters
and it has a moon that goes around it a
moon asteroid that's named amorphos 160
meters
dimorphos is about the size of a small
football field the plan send a
spacecraft with a body that's about the
size of a vending machine
and slam it into dimorphos and knock it
off course something that's never been
done before
and so this this whole challenge of
hitting a small asteroid when it's 11
million kilometers away when you have
very little information about what this
asteroid looks like at all and doing all
of that autonomously so the scientists
at Johns Hopkins developed away the
spacecraft could guide itself to the
intended target it's called smart nav it
had to be smart enough to tell the
difference between these two asteroids
within the last hour of the mission and
then command itself autonomously to fire
its thrusters to ensure it identified
dimorphos and hit demorphos head on
they chose an asteroid that was not a
threat to Earth the mission is
considered a success if they can alter
its direction the goal of Dart was
definitely all about asteroid deflection
not asteroid destruction the idea is
that this small nudge would add up to a
bigger change in its position with time
all right two minutes out
armed with a camera the spacecraft
provided NASA Mission Control real-time
images as it moved into place for impact
[Music]
it successfully collided with an
asteroid on September 26 2022 becoming
Humanity's first demonstration of
asteroid deflection it's a terribly
exciting that we've taken this first
step in what's called planetary defense
and it turns out the dart spacecraft did
a better job than anticipated it
significantly changed the asteroids
Direction the multi-million dollar
spacecraft was destroyed as planned but
the historic test is still providing new
data
of course all the important work being
done by NASA wouldn't have been possible
without the knowledge we gain from the
meteorites that land on Earth these
different materials are going to react
differently if you use a kinetic
impactor like Dart where you scratch a
spacecraft into it you can see where
that's going to react differently
depending on the composition of that
material
[Music]
one of the thousands of meteorites
Landing here on Earth crashed through
this roof in Golden British Columbia
a woman in western Canada had what you
might call a bad day a meteorite nearly
hit her the space junk landed right
where she was just sleeping
it came through the roof right up in
there
Ruth Hamilton was centimeters away from
being fatally struck by the space Rock
there was a loud crash I had no idea
where it came from I jumped out of bed
turned on the light and all I could see
was a hole in my ceiling I was so scared
I don't think I've ever been as scared
as anything else in my whole life At
first she didn't realize what she was
dealing with well at the time I didn't
know how special it was because it was
just a rock at that time and then later
on once we figured out it was a
meteorite
now this space Rock has its own special
case and has been named the golden
meteorite
this is some stuff off the roof that's
probably still some asphalt shingles and
a few pieces of wood from the roof for
scientific study Ruth provided the
meteorite to the team at Western
University in London Ontario they kept a
small chunk to examine and returned it
to Ruth
she's now receiving requests from all
over the world for this famous rock I
haven't quite decided what to do with it
there's lots of organizations out there
that want it you know some of them are
in museums some personal collectors and
to go on auction or whatever and I'm
just taking my time to decide what to do
that
foreign
so here we have our mineralogy and
petrology Museum which has rocks from
all over the Earth of different types
this is Canada's largest
university-based meteorite collection
more than 350 are housed at the
University of Alberta in Edmonton
Chris heard is a professor at the U of
A's Department of Earth and atmospheric
sciences
he's also the museum curator he would
love to add Ruth's meteorite to this
collection
so what are we looking at here these are
some of the finest specimens that we
have in our collection that represent
different types of meteorites
Chris also tracks shooting stars using
specialized cameras
the beauty of it is that if you have
enough observations of that fireball you
can calculate an orbit meaning you can
actually figure out where in the solar
system approximately that rock
originated from yeah
[Music]
important knowledge if we are going to
figure out where the next potentially
deadly asteroid might come from
he managed to capture these images of
the meteor on its journey to Ruth's
house
that one we picked up on one of our
cameras and there were other
observations as well that are being used
taken from Eastern Alberta the fireball
appears very low on the horizon and
quite faint I hear that western Canada
is a is a particularly good place for
this kind of work western Canada is a
pretty good place because we're in the
Prairies that's relatively flat there's
good sort of sight lines and also
because of the land use in this part of
the world is mostly for farming and you
know and ranching if something does fall
then the chances are better of actually
getting out and finding it on the
surface and being able to collect it
foreign
is also working on better ways to
preserve them which includes things like
keeping them cold and keeping them out
of the Earth's atmosphere and things
like that so that they are better
preserved over the long term
recently he was sent part of a
Han meteorite that fell in Somali
mald what he does he discovered was
quite surprising
there was some unusual looking minerals
inside really minerals that I couldn't
identify and so when we delved into it
more deeply we realized that we had
found at least two and it turns out
three Now new minerals minerals that
have never been found before in this
particular meteorite
his research in turn is used by NASA
because knowing what materials are in
meteorites helps with future asteroid
moving missions
the more that we can understand now
about these potentially hazardous
asteroids both in terms of their
physical properties and what they their
composition might be and also the
statistics of what's coming from where
that really does buy us time and
understand for when there might be
something even larger that is
potentially hazardous
it's all one connected universe
and the DART program continues to
process new data after its successful
mission
it's proving to be a crucial first step
toward a planetary defense system that
could save us one day
the good news is that once we have
identified track and are tracking
asteroids you can actually have warning
time of a hundred years
so you're in the situation where you
could do something like Dart where you
could just give it a small nudge many
years in advance and avoid a collision
with the planet